we're working with high-risk young moms
we're working with teens and young
adults with cancer and we're working
with college students who are facing
loneliness lack of social connection
what kind of intervention or support
might they need to get to a place where
they have better outcomes
this episode is proudly sponsored by CM
Bois many of you watching have heard of
Tristan Harris in the Center for Humane
technology we've done many episodes on
the perverse incentives around screen
time and critically thinking about what
balance truly maximizes our potential
Sampo built a new smartphone interface
and browser extensions as the new home
screen for humanity they're at a
crossroads looking for a new CEO to come
in or to partner with a larger
organization that has the resources to
bring this incredible technology to the
world they've built a high integrity
Foundation and our teed up for something
wonderful if interested message the
founder Andrew done at Andrew at cm poco
more infos in the bio
thanks everyone and enjoy the episode
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don Saucon we are at the
transformative technology conference for
our second partnership with them we are
now going to be talking about hope lab
we have Margaret Law joining us on the
show hi Margaret hi excited to be here
thanks for having me so pumped to have
you on the show
plump to talk about hope lab before we
get there we love asking all our guests
these questions are we really all one
really wow that's a pretty deep way to
start I think we are I think we are I
think you've got you're caught you've
got the kind of cosmic shirt on that's
cueing me to find my place in the
universe but I think I think so and I
think you know look a lot of what we do
at Hope Lab and I think a lot of what
brings people to a conference like this
is whether at whatever literal
metaphorical sort of way we take that
statement we're one at least to the
extent that we're really working for one
another and trying to help one another
and trying to
you know do the kind of work we do which
is to be one with one another to help
each other have the best possible
flourishing life we can yes I want to
hear about your experiences with
feelings of the one or feelings of
interconnectedness so are we like here
to talk about psychedelic journeys or we
you can take that wherever you want yeah
you know I I'm gonna I'm gonna keep it
to I'll keep it to the the hope lab in
the hope theme today and I think you
know you asked me this question and when
I reflect upon what brings me here and
what takes me to Hope lab every day and
what sort of drives me throughout my
life it is a feeling of that
interconnectedness and of how important
it is for me personally to be doing work
and sharing myself and hopefully often
my gifts with others and and I think
that that you know my I often say to
people that my work and my life are are
not distinct things that that a lot of
the incredible richness that I have in
my life through the relationships that I
have through the people that I meet
through the people I get to connect with
through the work that I do are you know
keep those things fused in a way that
it's just I feel incredibly lucky and
grateful and I feel grateful to be able
to do the work I do every day but also
to be among a community this community
here but the broader community of people
that I work with in health and
well-being that I think really does live
that and live that idea that that we're
connected we're one and we're trying to
make the world a better place and trying
to create opportunities for others to
have a better again more thriving
flourishing life yeah let's dive in so
what is hope lab doing especially in
solving this big issue with mental
health and well-being yeah well so hope
lab is now gosh we were founded 2000
2001 by Pam amid er Pam wife of eBay
founder Pierre Omidyar really wanted to
help young people with cancer have both
a better experience
better outcomes and so hopeful I was
founded to try to use technology to try
to use science research and technology
to improve health and life outcomes for
young people and what we do now is we've
broadened that out we still do some work
with young people with cancer but our
mission is to use tech to help teens and
young adults have happier healthier
lives and we're really really still
rooted in science and research we have a
staff of researchers designers and kind
of tech product managers and we try to
bring together some unusual partnerships
including a deep deep engagement with
young people as designers creators ideas
to try to understand opportunities to
and then execute on opportunities to
improve health and well-being okay so
walk us down this path of how to
actually figure out what do you mean
what do young people and adults in need
to live healthier happier lives in how
do you lever science technology research
to figure out what how do you deliver
these interventions that help people
live healthier happier lives
yeah so we're you know we're working
right now in a few big areas and I'll
start with those it doesn't exactly
answer your question but I'll come back
around to it we're working with high
risk young moms we're working with teens
and young adults with cancer and we're
working with college students who are
facing loneliness lack of social
connection so we're trying to think
about places in society where we have
created situations where young people
don't have great health and life
outcomes so we've got a lot of young
parents who if they don't get support
and help aren't going to have great
outcomes either for themselves or
further or for their kids young people
recovering from cancer going through
cancer treatment have statistically much
poorer outcomes for the social and
emotional outcomes for the couple of
years after treatment than their peers
and then finally you know we've gotta
this epidemic of loneliness social
isolation anxiety depression suicide
among college students young people in
that age group and so in each of those
situations we're trying to take a you
know
a deep human Center design approach so
to really work with young moms kids in
college young people recovering from
cancer treatment to understand where are
they now and what kind of support do
they need what kind of intervention or
support might they need to get to a
place where they have better outcomes
and how do they see that so how do they
see the path or the opportunities from
to get from you know where things are
not so great to where they can have much
better outcomes and we leverage the
power of research and science to do that
so we have a team of researchers and
that team will go deep into the
literature and what's known in the
science about things like social
connection loneliness positive
psychology cognitive behavioral therapy
all the things that that we've been
working with that can in an
evidence-based way show improvements and
then bring those together with that
design work we've done with young people
where we've deeply understood how they
live their lives what they care about
what motivates them what brings them joy
what their challenges are and through
that iterative process the team will
work on interventions and building an
intervention that in some way most of
the time we so far always involves a
tech element and often there's probably
a couple reasons for the tech piece of
it one is because that's where young
people are they're engaging with
technology in their day to day lives and
second because we want to try to build
things that can scale broadly and be
affordable and one of the ways to do
that is by leveraging the technology
that young people are using every day
there's so many questions yeah so anyway
some concrete questions let's break it
down
yeah let's begin this process so then we
have an example like at-risk moms and we
have this body of literature that has
all these different ways to come in and
make interventions around mental health
and well-being so then you have to do a
process of figuring out the current you
have to figure out how how is that
person an actual at-risk mom you figure
that out is there like some database
that you can pull at risk moms from and
then the next thing is how do you decide
on what kind of intervention you know
for someone that is like an at-risk mom
versus someone
that's a child that has cancer versus
someone that is just someone that's
struggling in college with a mental
health anxiety issues etc depression so
this is there's a whole suite of like
literature that has to be parsed for the
right sort of interventions for the
right sort of person I mean this is very
complicated so yeah let's let me try a
couple ways we break it down that I
think will help help you understand it
and others understand it so one concept
we use is we talk about reverse
engineering health so we think about a
health outcome we want and then we think
about the behaviors that contribute to
that health outcome so what are the
behaviors that are going to be make
somebody more likely or less likely to
have a positive health outcome to be
less lonely to be more connected to be
less anxious to have a better trajectory
with their baby and then we look at the
psychology that that acts on those
things and then we think about how
technology can impact that psychology
okay so let's have this example of the
mother and her child have some sort of
an app at risk observation situation and
then the intervention so like how or do
you know that there's an hour risk
situation happening yeah and then how do
you calculate the proper intervention
well that brings in partnerships so in
that case that the at-risk moms the
young moms were working with are all
engaged in a program with an
organization called nurse Family
Partnership so they're all engaged in
this program and they've been chosen for
that because they are low income and
high risk and they've generally grown up
in poverty and they have delivered a
baby early in their life so that they're
pregnant early in their life this is the
template so that's the template said
we're starting and then we're looking at
this question of what are the things
that that we can understand from the
science and from the experience of the
program that are most likely to lead
that mom to have a positive outcome and
in this case one of the things that we
learn and it's kind of simple but it's
probably related to a lot of what we're
talking about here today is learning to
set work towards and achieve goals
that's something that you know you and I
might take for granted but a lot of the
lot of the technologies that we're
seeing out there for all sorts of people
really are are helping us to try to do
that to try to have healthy behaviors by
learning to set work towards and achieve
goals so the aha for
in this program was that if we could
build a really engaging technology
intervention tool in this case looks
like it takes the form of an app that
could help those young moms do that in
places in their life that were really
important to them that that would result
in them having better outcomes in all
kinds of way it helped them so it'll be
more likely to get an education be more
likely not to harm or risk their child
be more likely to read to the kid all
the things that you want to see
happening okay and then so then there's
a targeted intervention that happens to
do one of these goal-oriented behaviors
that maximizes their life outcome in the
life outcome of their kid so then you
send how many yeah then what we do is we
build that and test it so we work with
partners we actually brought a tech
partner called a yo go in that has a
really interesting platform they're
gamers and behavioral scientists so
they've got this behavior change
platform they can build white-label
products and we worked with them to
design and build this platform it's
called goal mama in this case I love
that name my name is good mama we're
thinking about gold Papa actually um so
then we build this and then we have to
test it so we have to actually
understand a couple things about it we
have to understand whether the young
moms to whom it's targeted or for whom
we've built it like using it is it
exciting is it engaging is it something
that they want to use and then we need
to understand basically whether it's
working to get the results that we're
trying to get does it keep them in the
program does it get them more likely to
do the things that we want to see them
do like finish school like read to their
kids like have healthy nutrition and
stay off of drugs all those things that
that we're trying to accomplish - ed is
it like self-reported that they're
achieving these goals are like how do
you know that they're yeah I mean in
this particular program and this one's
not that this each one of these programs
that if we're gonna describe a couple of
them is a little different we will yeah
and some of it depends on who the
partner is so in this case this this was
a partner that had a program in place
and what was interesting about the
program was even though it was targeted
at teen and young moms
it was did not use digital at all and so
40 years ago that wasn't a big deal when
this program started there wasn't any
digital nobody was carrying around a
phone but fast-forward 40 years to today
you have a program that's targeting
teens and and women in their 20s and if
you don't deliver it to them digitally
it's gonna be very hard to keep them
engaged and so in this case we were
really looking at how do we actually
meet the needs of today's young moms and
do that in a way that's going to be
really resonant with them so we spent
our team spent a lot of time out with
young moms in the field so we went out
into their homes we shadowed them we
talked to them then when we engage them
in the design and then tested with them
so a big big important piece of what
we're able to do you know I call Hope
lab we call Hope love a social
innovation lab what we're able to do is
run this lab where we can take a
principle like you should really have
your target users in this case young
moms deeply engaged in designing and
developing the product we can do that we
have the luxury in some ways you know
we're not we're not out trying to you
know hit quarterly earnings we've got a
little bit of flexibility and how we can
work and so a big big piece of how we
use that benefit and how we use that
flexibility is to engage young people at
every step of the way
designing developing testing the stuff
that we work on okay let's given this
just I really want to try and synthesize
this into some sort of like a concrete
understanding of exactly what's
happening with the moms that are at risk
I'm gonna do my best and you tell me if
this makes sense we can move on to the
other ones okay
so a mom is at risk maybe having a child
a little bit too early maybe she's a
young mother etc let's say 18 year old
and haven't had a lot of social support
in her life doesn't have a lot of social
support yeah these are this is huge
absolutely huge this is this is life
trajectory changing in interventions
that's why this is extremely important
okay then there's a bunch of literature
around ways to cast these interventions
into people's lives depending on who
this person is exactly
that intervention comes in and it comes
in a specialized way for different again
these different cases that you are
listing that we'll get to in a little
bit in this case it may be something
that is some sort of a digital
notification for them to dive deeper
into like a reading with their child or
take the child to some sort of an
educational place or to get these goals
around like what do you want to achieve
in the next year or in the next three
years maybe there's somebody that you go
and meet with but so it's these
different sort of strategies around kind
of like becoming their like self
actualization coach in a sense and and
for not only them but literally the
child that that that they need and the
social fabric that may not be conducive
to them in this in this case or their
their friends and family etc
there's oh there's this it's again its
life trajectory changing was that okay
that was great and I think that but I
will add something that's really
important and it's important in both to
the understanding the story but also I
think to what we're doing so in this
particular program the person does have
an in-person coach
it's a nurse and the person the young
mom meets with that nurse every couple
of weeks and what's interesting about
this is that when we set out to design
this one of the principles that was
really important to us and was really
important to the partner in the project
was that the technology wasn't meant to
take the place of the person the
technology was really meant to amplify
the relationship between this nurse and
this mom a lot of the things that we're
seeing develop in the space of coaching
and connection we care a lot about the
human touch in the human element and one
of the things for me just in my career
and in my career with digital health and
digital interventions over the past
couple of decades has been to really
think about how do we do a better job of
combining the human touch with the the
power of technology and digital and so
one of the most interesting things about
this program is that what that in this
project that we've worked on is that
what it's really trying to do is to say
how do we have the human how do we how
do we use this human to do the things
that humans are really great at and how
do we bring technology in to really
amplify
that and so in this case we've got these
young moms who are meeting with these
nurses and now this technology tool
helps everybody connect more connecting
between visits be more efficient track
what's getting done yes holes so that's
I think an important I love that this is
like we just like you just described the
human still being in the loop for a know
deep emotional psyche to psyche
interaction is so crucial especially if
it's happening weekly these types of
let's move to the next well because
these are very important like I was just
saying like these are life trajectory
changing interventions that's what I
love about them you know you just view
it like someone's life trajectory going
like trying to get to as much of their
like peak thing that their blueprinted
for gifting into the world and sometimes
people are just going like this until
they die instead of going up in the
least amount of time and you guys can in
a sense intervene and help people get up
and we're all about this on that the
show yeah yeah so we have this next one
which is young people that have been
diagnosed with cancer so the
intervention that we developed the the
product is called viv ABAT so what we
were trying to do was we were looking at
this problem and the problem was poor
social function lots of anxiety and
depression as kids are coming out of
young people are coming out of cancer
treatment kid teens and young adults and
there's all sorts of reasons for that
it's a big identity formation time in
life and so you were a football player
and then you became you know then
instead of whatever that identity had
been you're now a cancer patient how do
you get out of that how do you get back
to a new normal identity so that was a
big piece of it there's a big piece of
it around it's just tough you've been
out of school you've lost connection
with your peers so there's lots of
reasons that explain it and so what we
wanted to try to do is to to we knew
that we knew that that would there was
documented scientific evidence that
anxiety and depression were higher that
social function was poorer for these
young people and so we really wanted to
see if we could do something about that
and so we got again got together a lot
of you
people with cancer going through cancer
treatment and we spent time with them
developing uh you know about a dozen
concepts initially and we ultimately
converged on one concept which was a way
to deliver a positive psychology
intervention because our science team
had determined boy a lot of the things
that young people are experiencing
during this time if we could teach them
the principles and the skills of
positive psychology gratitude
mindfulness we could help them have have
less anxiety and better outcomes and
then the other part that was really
interesting about it was the form factor
and so we've ended up developing a bot
is a chat bot called viv Abad and the
you know it could have been in person
groups that met together that's what we
thought it might be initially it could
have been an app but it could have been
you know some way of connecting them
with someone who'd gone through
something similar to what they had done
and the insight that we got from the
young people was a really interesting
one and it was you know right now the
people in my life I you know I'm so
thankful for the support that I have in
my life but when I'm not feeling so
great or or when I need to vent I can't
go to them they either people either
feel sorry for me or they don't want me
to feel bad and I just don't feel like I
can be I don't feel like I have a
non-judgmental place I can go so if this
if this thing could be kind of like a
person but not a person not another
person that would be great and that
insight led to the concept of making
this bot which is a person like you know
it has a chat with you it's a chat bot
so the juxtaposing this would lower just
talk which is interesting actually
hearing that that that big insight from
the young people was a really important
one which is I need something that I
that can be non-judgmental and that I
can interact with and I can at 3:00 in
the morning if I'm feeling low I can go
out there and there will be somebody to
talk to that won't judge me
and so viv about was built and it
they're the two big things that come out
through the bots are a chat which
introduces and teaches positive
psychology skills
and then videos and the videos are of
other young people talking about the
experiences that they've had going
through cancer so they're really
wonderful
you know first person young people
talking about this is what happened when
I had to think about you know fertility
or this is what happened when I you know
when people you know kept telling me you
should feel grateful because you're
better you know you're not you're not
going to die and yeah yeah so the bots
in the intervention juxtaposed those two
things and deliver them for the young
people and they have access to it 24/7
and the exciting thing about viv bots is
just last week we actually released in
the Journal of medical internet research
a study showing that it significantly
reduced symptoms of anxiety in young
people with cancer so one of the
important things for us a totally thank
you one of the important things for us
at Hope lab is that we do the scientific
validation and testing of the work we do
so that was published last week we were
really excited and proud about that and
we have now moved with a bot to a formal
home outside the lab think of a bot was
in the lab now we have about what we
want move about living out in the world
and we've partnered with an organization
called grit gr whitey and they're the
biggest online community social
community for young people with cancer
and their families and loved ones and so
bob is now available for free for young
people with cancer and those who love
them and support them and and people can
go out and give it a try and please
refer anybody who you know who might
benefit from yeah that was really it's
an exciting Wow Wow yeah I love this I
love the second one being so much
different at Hope Lab than the first one
that you're like at-risk moms are so
much different than children are young
adults that have cancer that are killing
through cancer treatment and that are in
such a part like when you talked about
their identity becoming that that like
really resonates because it's a such a
formative part of your life and like if
you can't get out of
at foreign parts collec if you go to
jail when you're young or if you but
like cancer is another thing but like a
baby maybe like I risk yeah there's all
yeah these are very interesting in a
very interesting way of putting it that
there's all these different types of
things that can happen that are stimuli
on your life that are in many ways hard
to see ask some sort of like a treasure
like a trauma being a treasure but once
you do get through that process of
seeing the the God in it the source and
at the unity and it the love in it the
dough awakening the further evolution of
consciousness in it then it's so hard to
see that because here we are being
healthy 27 you know years old and trying
to compare that to having a child to
earlier having cancer so early but it is
in a source it is in a sense source
creatively expressing itself and finding
these beautiful adventures of
consciousness it's so hard to view it
that way though and things we talk about
though at a principle higher level is
you know we're trying to help
think about this period of adolescence
and young adulthood instead of as one of
a risk negative risk as one of great
opportunity and so there's a piece of
the when you talk about identity
formation there's a piece of all the
work we do when we work with this age
group which is all our work now is
focusing on teens and young adults that
really is about that right it's about
identity formation and about opportunity
and about this sort of this notion that
there's lots of risks that happen around
that time of life how can we actually
help take that that propensity for
risk-taking or for risk that that goes
along with that phase of life and try to
sort of turn it to the positive yeah and
so this notion of the opportunity for
flourishing versus the risks of terrible
things happening is really something
important that drives us so you really
hit on it I love that seeing it as
opportunity for flourishing catalyzing
that opportunity for flourishing
than trauma that can send us down and
depression spiral all these different
this is such a profound way viewing it
okay and this was another very
interesting just way of explaining like
this is a completely different class of
intervention that is in a sense like
somewhat of a bot that's accessible
anytime for someone to be able to talk
to and and actually this also reminds us
of just the recent episode we did with
with inner allies and that could be
something that Hope lab could
potentially explore partnering with as
well these interventions the array of of
mental emotional health interventions
that come in for maximizing well-being
at these critical pivotal times is its
be exploding that's why we're here at
Transtech um there's a still a third one
that we're gonna explore here and this
one is blowing up in our world it has a
lot to do with these with these devices
it has a lot to do with the attention
economy and the business plans behind
them and has a lot to do with the way
that we are just it feels like we're our
biology has not caught up with cultural
evolution and here we are stuck in the
exponential technology age with
primordial brains and then you have all
these college kids that are like looking
at people saying like they have ten
million subscribers and I have nothing
and then we kind of like forget that
we're own all unique colors on the color
wheel uniquely blue printed four
different things and that it's not about
that comparison it's about that inner
adventure and happiness and so what the
hell do we do about depression and
anxiety with yeah yeah I'll talk a
little bit about well there's this
project we're doing in this intervention
that we've created because I think it it
it won't answer that question but it
gets to a lot of interesting points and
in some ways it raises like everything
we do it raises as many questions as it
answers so we were trying to we decided
we really wanted to enter the space of
teen young adult mental well-being and
we wanted to characterize it as broader
than health or sort of mental illness
but mental focusing on mental well
and so we looked at this question of
what contributes to the current state of
teen young adult mental well-being or
lack thereof in the US and we did this
thing called a systems map which is a
very interesting process and without
going into that in detail a number of
places on that map emerged loneliness
and lack of social connection it emerged
in the area you talked about which is
this area of social media in emerging
communities and people having less
connection to community and so we
decided we wanted to kind of go down
that path and see whether there was
something that we might be able to do
that could look at so with the way we
look at this is we think of loneliness
and we don't think of it what science
shows that loneliness is a precursor to
and predictor of depression anxiety and
even suicide and so it's upstream as we
would say in in the healthcare world but
it's really important because if you
could intervene at that point then maybe
you could stop some of the depression
and anxiety that we're seeing escalate
in society that's actually your key
essence of hope lab ISM everything
upstream as far upstream as possible
interventions for maximizing well-being
I love that so so what we did was we
thought about okay what you know we went
out did a lot of interviews and a lot of
discussions with with kids and we ended
up focusing on college just because of
it as an inflection point so we talked
about this is a time of change and also
because there's been this huge as you've
read about in the news this huge
challenge in college campuses so one
statistic is you know there's been five
times the increase in demand on college
counseling centers as there has been
increasing college attendance so five
five minutes and so the colleges can't
keep up with that and it does raise this
question of gosh what is causing this
huge demand for services in these
college counseling and mental health
centers and so we began to look at this
this kind of health outcome behavior
psychology technology map that I talked
about a little bit before and we ended
up deciding that we would try to create
an intervention that was targeting
loneliness or the opposite of loneliness
social connection again after spending a
lot of time talking with young people
understanding how
they characterize and talk about
loneliness hearing them talk about
things like you know no one ever taught
me how to make a friend you know it's
just really interesting things that I
think are things that we we have changes
that we've seen in society that I my
experience online and my experience in
real life don't connect the way I would
like them to that it's hard for me I
feel lonely it's hard for me to reach
out and make a social connection with
other people it feels too risky it feels
like I'm going to be rejected and so
there's a lot that came into this this
whole concept of if we could help young
people both learn how to make social
connections but also have the skills
that they need to process rejection to
process challenges that that might be
something that could have an impact on
anxiety depression and how do we do that
and so what we did was we went back you
you we'll take you back to where you
were earlier in our conversation we went
back to the science and we looked at you
know what are the pathways that we think
we might be able to impact between
loneliness and anxiety or loneliness and
depression
how might social connection and learning
the skills of positive social connection
be a buffer to loneliness and be a
antidote to loneliness anxiety
depression and so what we ended up doing
was designing an intervention which this
one takes the form of an app it's called
nod and we just actually launched it you
know randomized controlled trial on the
University of Oregon campus about a
month and a half ago so now you're gonna
have all the University of Oregon kids
wondering if they're all out there using
it right now so and basically what what
it does is it it it plays with this idea
that I talked about earlier of young
people teens and young adults are are
their brain is wired to take risks and
so we thought well what if you could
actually use that and create a series of
positive social risks so what if you
could create a game or an experience for
young people where you give them a set
of social risks to take and it can be a
social risk as simple as you know go sit
down and talk to three new people at
today or make eye contact with people as
you walk across campus or bring a friend
some bring somebody something from the
dining hall you know be the friend you
would want to be so social challenges
which may seem simple but are things
that people aren't doing or feeling like
they can't do and then give them the
tools to process their feelings their
experiences and you know do that through
them having the opportunity both to
reflect on them so we give you like a
lot of the meditation and sort of
wellness apps teach reflections give
people the opportunity to to do that
processing and then teach the skills of
self compassion so that adds they're
having these experiences if things don't
go so well they learn this skill also
part of a lot of what we see out there
in the world of mindfulness apps of
learning self compassion so we package
this together into an intervention and
we're testing that intervention and what
we're doing is we're testing we're
asking the question does it decrease
loneliness yeah so we're doing pre and
post-tests on loneliness and then does
it decrease feelings of our symptoms of
depression yeah and we're doing that
test as we roll it out so we designed
that with interestingly another company
called grit this one spelled GRI TK it's
based in Denver it's a theme it's a it
was a trendy it was a trendy thing for a
year so that company grit that
organization has a portal on college
campuses called you at college so they
were an interesting partner for us
because they were already reaching out
to college kids and we worked with them
and kind of in their sandbox to design
this this intervention visually to make
it interesting to young people to get
the language and the kind of syntax and
the way that jokes the the pictures so
we did that design work again tested it
with lots of young people and now the
test we're going through now is is
really the test of can this intervention
have an impact on loneliness
among these first-year college students
and we'll have a little bit of
information about that in the early part
of yeah it seems
again very common sense that by nudging
people into the very small social
emotional intelligence interactions that
they will decrease feelings of
disconnectedness and separation and
increase feelings of interconnection and
well-being less depression less
loneliness etc like and it's just so
interesting that again you know your
essence going in this direction of the
most upstream early life interventions
that help catalyze people's futures love
that about Hope lab at the same time it
seems like if you go even more upstream
than you guys fixing symptoms is even
more upstream is the root of the issue
being separation you're born into the
world and it's all about separation the
United States culture these college
campuses roar with economic separation
political and social separation it
because this is the world that we've
bred it's no longer understanding every
breath of air every sip of water every
bite of food and the interconnected
processes that every word that's
exchanged between people just look back
at indigenous people and the way that
they still live today and that the use
of live a hundred thousand years ago and
their deep animism with their
environment and with each other and when
you look at that and you try and bring
that into metropolis and into the most
upstream when the child's born into the
world and the social fabric around us it
will make it so that all the other
symptom issues go away do you feel like
the most upstream issue is our tendency
toward separation and our disconnection
yeah it's so it's so interesting to hear
you play it out this way because one of
the things that that has really been
striking to me about this particular
project has been you know that the
statistic is basically that two-thirds
of college kids say they felt very
lonely sometime in the past you know a
month I think we asked her a couple
months and that's kind of incredible
because to your point if you think about
what that says about us as a culture and
and what that says even what we had one
of our interns who wrote this great blog
piece which you should read on our site
about you know just
what that means that means as I sit here
in the as I sit here in my Hall of other
students at this in this class I look to
my left I look to my right we all feel
lonely we all feel like we don't have
social connection and yet here we all
are together and for some reason that
that's the condition we find ourselves
in and so to me what's interesting and I
know to our researchers I was talking
with one of the with our director of
research operations this notion of sort
of this epidemic of loneliness is really
an interesting thing to your point for
us to delve deeper into because if we if
we're delivering our young people to
college all feeling disconnected and
lonely disaster what is that what does
that mean for how we're engaging and
behaving as a society and it can't I
mean you can't I totally agree with you
we say okay great now we have them
two-thirds of them are lonely let's see
if we can do something to try to help
fix this now let's see if we can do
something to get them in this teachable
moment when they're just starting
college that maybe will help them get to
connect it to some people so that they
won't have that experience through
college
it doesn't obviate the need to do
something earlier but it it definitely
and it definitely gets you thinking when
it's that prevalent what is it that the
most upstream yeah and what is it and
what is it that we're that we are as a
society telling young people about yeah
you know themselves are about what is
the social fabric of existence if really
they're getting to that point in
thinking you know I am disconnected I
don't yeah I don't know what my gifts
are no we know the social fabric helps
people accelerate them finding their
gifts instead last question that we like
asking our guests on so we've done such
a great job on packing whole Bob at
least I feel even given the short time
and maybe we can do more epic
conversations into what exactly like
more Hope lab as well as other important
organizations around the world like you
guys are doing like all the partners
that you listed as well are so
interesting the last question is what do
you think is
the most beautiful thing in creation Wow
huh the most beautiful thing in creation
you know this is sort of like the this
is the question that that somebody asks
the other day when we were doing an
icebreaker which is you know sunrise or
sunset and I think that I think for me
just to sort of as I go through my day
and you know my life and reflection a
friend of mine you know says she makes
sure to watch the sunset every day and I
think that that for me you know just
this this revelation every night and
every day that we've that we've sort of
got a new a new beginning that there's a
that there's a moment of contemplation
the sunset conflation and the moment of
new beginning in sunrise I think that
phenomenon I don't know if that's
captures me and it grounds me in a way
that I I sort of get the opportunity to
to really think about intention and sort
of how do i how do i not let that go and
how do i remember that there are these
opportunities every single day to have
and really you know operate on intention
yes there's my deep thought for you yes
yes thanks for prompting it in me
oh this has been so fun learning more
about you and hope laughs thank you
thanks Margaret thank you thanks for
having me wow thank you so much thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it check out the links in the
bio below it's hopeless or check out
that link in the bio below also check
out the other links in the bio below
this is very important we got to figure
this out all these topics that we talked
about on the show with what Hope lab is
doing have more conversations with your
friends families co-workers people
online about these subjects check out
the links in the bio below two
transformative technology conference and
all the incredible things that they're
doing here and all the organizations
that are part of this check out those
links in the Bible oh Thank You Brady
stronger for co-producing the show
appreciate your thank you very much also
support the artists the arch Brewers the
organizations around the world that you
believe in in general support them and
help them grow you can find all of our
links in the bio below to simulation
paypal patreon cryptocurrency can design
cool merch and get paid all those links
on the bio below check this out and go
and build the future everyone manifest
your dreams into the world we love you
very much thank you for tuning in and we
will see you soon
[Music]